a 26 year old man who was a serial
online blackmailer has been sentenced to
32 years in prison abdul allahi targeted
almost 2 000 women and young girls using
fake identities to build a bank of
images of sexual abuse which he then
sold online in box sets to other
pedophiles lisa dowd is at birmingham
crown court for us hello to you lisa
what has happened today
well abdul allahi has just been
sentenced and in court we heard how he
had been living a unremarkable life in
birmingham but behind his devices in his
bedroom in the city of birmingham he was
committing abuse and blackmail on an
industrial scale the investigators who
looked into him described him as a
sadistic pedophile with thousands of
victims in 34 different countries in
fact his own defense barrister described
him as one of the worst online predators
ever apprehended and what he was doing
was posing as a rich middle-aged
businessman on the so-called sugar daddy
websites and there he found
young vulnerable female victims women
and girls who were desperate and in debt
and he described to police in his own
custody interview how he would groom his
victims
one week i was posing as a doctor the
next i
was a banker
following week entrepreneur lying coming
up with fake jobs constantly it was just
mainly threatening about exposure to be
honest and different
different spins on that
pornhub family
before anything figure out her financial
situation the less money she has the
more willing
the kinkier she's willing to be
so once i had that information i'd give
them my um my offer
if they were stupid and i could blag it
i'd mention 10 grand or 20 grand
sometimes the girls would believe it and
they said oh how can i make more and
then i just say kinkier stuff
what began as him requesting naked
images in return for money escalated to
him blackmailing victims into
horrifically abusing themselves their
siblings and children and we spoke to
one victim who told us what they went
through
it started off as just laundry pictures
and previous pictures of just like
selfies so like just my face like
just normal pictures really so it didn't
really start any alarm bells early on
just eventually asked for more and more
like naked photos and then more like
violent and graphic pictures so
violence on like inflicting on myself
asking if i've got younger siblings if i
knew any like close people that were
younger than me obviously like
for like paedophilic reasons
i think it definitely makes you think
that it's your own fault when the people
closest to you don't believe you
police found on his devices 67 000
indecent images of children which he was
selling as a box sets to like-minders of
view like-minded abusers he made 25 000
pounds out of doing that and he was
acting as a mentor for other abusers who
became copycat abusers as well and we
had some reaction from the national
crime agency who investigated him
it is right up there in terms of the
size and scale of this offending
absolutely we've had similar ones but
this 158 indictments is going to take
some beating in terms of size and scale
so the sentence
fits the crime he's a very very twisted
deviant uh callous individual and he
should and was punished severely for
what are very very serious crimes it
sends out a clear message that we will
pursue people like
and that they will be punished
very very severely by the courts
the judge described
lahi as a depraved and prolific offender
and she sentenced him to 32 years in
prison when he is eventually released
though he will spend eight years on
license so he'll have to stick to
certain conditions and he will be placed
on the sex offenders register for life
investigators have managed to recover a
hundred thousand images online that he
posted but there are many more out there
that they will never be able to recover
and that will concern his victims for
life because they could be exposed to
further blackmailers
really horrific case lisa dao thank you